ich dachte echt so dass mit dem keyboard
wer was hallo mein name ist nun kann ich
habe eine ganz besondere beziehung mit
dem clever bot
leute der clever bot will mit mir
zusammen sein hier gerade bereits sehen
content der klever bord und ich
mittlerweile ein liebespärchen und
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht gehen wir
heute mal wieder auf die seite clever
bord und werden mal wieder mit dem
clever bord ein wenig darüber reden was
denn in unserer beziehung so vor sich
geht denn seit einer woche habe ich
nicht mehr mit ihm geredet und wenn man
in einer beziehung ist ist eine woche
nicht miteinander reden schon ein
bisschen komisch in der tat ich fange
mal ganz vorsichtig an mit hey wie gehts
dir lieber clever bord mal schauen was
er darauf antwortet das hatten wir schon
wir haben eine woche nicht miteinander
geredet das hatten wir noch nicht
punkt um punkt und wie geht es dir also
ich weiß nicht ob wir das jetzt wirklich
schon hatten immer noch google ein
zwinker zwinker smileys bedeuten nie
etwas gutes warum schreibst du zwinker
smiley lieber clever bot das ist ein
sehr komisches mal war ich dich
kennenlernen
wie alt bist du
wir sind zusammen die sind doch zusammen
clever bot punkt um punkt also dachte
ich jetzt zumindest seit dem letzten
video was ich hochgeladen habe stimmt ok
zumindest an das kann er sich noch
erinnern wir hatten nun seit einer woche
keinen kontakt mehr lieber clever bot
das hat mich ein bisschen traurig
gemacht sein vor einer woche habe ich ja
das video hochgeladen wo ich mit
was von 1 vor einer woche habe ich das
letzte mal mit clever bot ein video
hochgeladen wieso sagst du nein lieber
clever board also ich habe euch ja
gerade nochmal den screenshot
eingeblendet natürlich vor einer woche
hatten jetzt mal kontakt weil ich ne
ansage
warum leon was schauen was er darauf
jetzt antwortet ich meinte nein
wenig die nicht mal mehr so viel wert
dass du für mich richtig schreiben
kannst wieso gibst du dir so wenig mühe
also nicht nur der hinsicht dass wir
lange keinen kontakt hatten sondern auch
beim schreiben lieber clever bot finde
ich mache ich mir ein bisschen gedanken
weil du einen computer bis das hatten
wir letztes mal schon
ich bin kein computer ich bin ein mensch
punkt um punkt das hatten wir doch schon
mal also ich muss mich ja nicht
verstellen ich bin halt nun einfach mal
ein mensch über klamotten und wie heißt
du luca
beschreibt nicht mal
wir sind zusammen clever bot wieso soll
ich mich beschreiben also für mich macht
das ehrlich gesagt gerade alles nicht so
richtig sinn lieber teraport wir sind
auch zusammenhalt so
was halt so wie halt so punkt um punkt
was meinst du fragezeichen fragezeichen
fragezeichen
das was du eben auf englisch gesagt hast
ich spreche deutsch über klamotten ich
habe auch gerade mit den die ganze zeit
auf deutsch gesprochen also ich hab
nichts sehen wir auf englisch gesagt
okay wie alt bist du das hatten wir
alles letzte woche schon ich bin 22 und
du lieber clever bord 17 okay das ist
schön
und wie geht es dir mein name ist luca
lieber clever bot man wir sind doch
zusammen lukas kritiker sich ziemlich
komplett verarschen mann lukas kennst du
irgendwelche interessanten geschichten
klein geschrieben also rechtschreibung
ist nicht so dass bei der
rechtschreibung nicht vorhanden da es
auch nicht so viel speicher
viel speicher
scheiß auf oder
oder der ist die schlimmste beleidigung
ist viel speicher wieso machst du jetzt
so bühlmann ich dachte wir wären in
einer beziehung zusammen also ich
versteh wollen wir jetzt zieht mich hier
beleidigt als viel speicher schreiben
deswegen machen also frage jetzt mal
einfach liebst du mich lieber clever bot
also einfach mal direkt nein ich kenne
dich nicht freunde in der stelle muss
ich ganz ehrlich gesagt anmerken ich
überlege unsere beziehung zu beenden
lieber clever bot wir sind seit letzter
woche zusammen seit ich bin aber ein
mädchen und du auf das geht dann nicht
ich bin ein junge was magst du denn so
letztes mal das auch schon dass der kerl
aber dachte ich sei ein mädchen oder so
keine ahnung was das soll
aber ich schreibe jetzt einfach mal so
ich mag dich über clever bot also was
magst du denn so ich mag dich weil wir
sind jetzt zusammen mit du kennst mich
doch gar nicht ich kenne die natürlich
nach wohl kenne ich dich wir sind doch
zusammen lieber clever und wir sind doch
in einer beziehung ja sind wir auch aber
warum liebst du mich dann nicht dann
sagt mir doch dass du mich liebst die
bei clever bot das kann doch nicht so
schwierig sein ich liebe dich cook wir
sind wirklich zusammen in einer
beziehung das habt ihr davon die ganzen
hater also sind wir noch in einer
beziehung lieber clever bot das möchte
jetzt von dir wissen das ist richtig
okay wir sind noch in einer beziehung
freunde ich muss mir aber ganz ehrlich
ich möchte mir ein bäh es ist ich
bemerke ich bin am stottern das ist ein
sehr sehr schwieriges thema für mich
neben das damit dass sich damit euch
dann darüber rede ich würde sagen da
müssen wir uns mal ganz kurz an anderen
ort bewegen
[Musik]
ich dachte echt so dass mit dem
kellerwald wer was ernstes weil ich ja
mit ihm darüber geredet hatte letzte
woche und wir haben uns viele nette
sachen geschrieben und dann mega lieb
zueinander und voll so einen lauf und so
und ja jetzt hat sich das irgendwie
anders ein bisschen entwickelt dass er
mich gar nicht mehr richtig kennt und
ich weiß nicht eventuell das licht
unserer beziehung erloschen ist
freunde ich blende euch jetzt einfach
mal die oben eine abstimmung ein also da
könnt ihr auf dem handy oder auf dem pc
einfach draufklicken könnt abstimmen hey
ja soll ich in der nächsten folge die
beziehung mit dem clever bord beenden
soll ich schluss machen oder soll ich es
nicht machen soll ich weiter mit ihm
zusammen sein ihr könnt da oben up
stellen es geht jetzt natürlich noch
weiter aber ich möchte jetzt mit dem
quad nicht mehr über unsere liebe reden
sondern eher ein bisschen über andere
themen also ich weiß nicht ob dr
das ob wir mit euch darin nicht so ein
bisschen hineinversetzen können weil das
ist für mich im also dass das nimmt mich
schon ein bisschen mit und ich will das
ist für mich sehr ernsten ernstes thema
und ich will das wird das nicht
überstürzen
stimmt ab
dann machen was in der nächsten folge
aber jetzt wir reden wir weiter mit ihm
ich schreibe einfach sorry hatte gerade
was wichtiges zu tun lieber clever bot
an weil ich war jetzt auch eine
viertelstunde nicht bei ihm ich heiße
mag ich bin 19 jahre alt und liebe 17
jahre schon in amerika war schön markt
punkt ich dachte du seist ein mädchen
das hat er mir auch vorhin gesagt lieber
clever bot ich weiß ich bis jetzt marc r
nein bin ich nicht
vorher war
das was lieber clever bot was dass ich
nicht da wo wäre das bist du eigentlich
für eine fette bis geburt ich sagte du
bist ein mädchen und heißt mag und jetzt
sagt er dass er nicht da wo wert heißt
also ja es kommt ja hinter weil ich
dachte auch vorhin einig dass er ein
mädchen ist ja ich bin ein mann weil ich
bin 18 rubin war er noch mag und 19 wo
hast du 17 jahre deines lebens gelebt
weil findet er ja gesagt er 17 jahre
lang in amerika gelebt mal schauen was
der körper passiert sagt ein bauch im
bauch meiner mutter
17 jahre hat der kletterwand im bauch
seiner mutter gelebt seine mutter war er
lange zeit so richtig fett punkt wenn
sie 17 jahre langen kind in sich drin
hatte du nicht
nein ich bin dünn es zu den planeten
erde jahre ja natürlich
warum
wo liegt die erde unter mir also ich
stehe ja drauf
hier geht es um mathematik aber
denn ich bin ein genie nein antworte ich
da einfach mal so wie justin das sagen
würde stimmt gut erkannt wer bist du
denn frage ich jetzt einfach mal weil
wenn er kein genie ist aber mir sagt
dass ein genie ist boden sagt er seien
mädchen und wieder keine mich in das ein
junge dann ist das wirklich mag ich bin
eine freundin noch kommt drauf an ja wie
die abstimmung hier aus geht also bin
ich dein freund lieber clever bot nur
noch mal damit ist aus deinem mund hören
nein du bist ein niedriger
ich bin ich kann nicht schreiben die oft
noch lieber clever wort also das kann
doch irgendwie echt ich war sein die
ganze zeit sage ich ich bin ein junge
wie du sagst du dann du wärst meine
freundin daran erkennt man dass du ein
computer bist wtf das macht vorne hinten
und an den seiten keinen sinn das macht
keinen sinn an drei ausrufezeichen ich
bin ein mensch lieber clever was ich
verstehe nicht was daran so schwer zu
verstehen ist glauben doch einfach ich
schreib doch hier mit dir wie geht es
dir egal ob sich komplett verarschen die
heißt wisst ihr was erst denkt ich bin
computer dann bin ich million
dann bin ich ein mädchen da wieder ein
junger da wieder mädchen
als lukas
diana und jetzt weiß er
mehr wie ich heiße an der stelle ganz
ehrlich da bin ich einfach raus anderer
stelle will ich das heute wieder
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren wie gesagt findet ihr hier eine
umfrage eingeblendet bzw die
eingeblendet bekommen dass ihr bestimmen
dürfte wie es mit dem clever bord
weitergehen soll also soll ich in der
nächsten folge schluss machen oder soll
ich es noch mal probieren stimmt er
einfach ab oder schreibt mir eure
meinung in die kommentare last ein
leichter wenn euch selber wird videos
gefallen meine damen und herren schaffen
die 50.000 likes ich weiß es ist eine
menge aber ich habe gesehen dass erich
klemm aber immer noch spaß macht auf
meinem kanal und deswegen also wenn es
euch gefällt das gerne mal ein leichter
und so als würde ich an der steller ja
so einfach nur noch sagen